[Music]
all of you all at once here having a
good time seeing the fans react to
something like this I mean it's bigger
than life in many ways
no it is a lot of fun and you know I've
only so far on these to work a week and
it was with mark
it was just with Mark and Scarlett the
whole time so we were just sitting on
that said having a great day pair people
based on their height what was the
reaction for you guys I mean like these
fans are so like enthusiasm is a little
overwhelming I found it really
overwhelming as well I had no idea how
big the room was Kurt was opened up a
night I was told I was like a deer in
the headlights I'd you know so much
noise so much excitement it was amazing
it was you know obviously I can say that
I met a couple people for the first time
on stage I met special Sebastian Sam for
the first time on stage I mean it's a
big cast um so yeah I have not met
everybody I was chasing around looking
for Don Cheadle I've not met him when I
grew up loving them tricky things is we
get to see each other in such small
bites you know and we do a little thing
together and then we don't see each
other again for months I mean there's 72
people I figured if we each got three
minutes of screen time the movie would
be a three hour movie yeah yeah yeah I
mean so you know you never get enough
time but it's it's the best of the best
dr. strange Benedict Cumberbatch
and then dr. strange being part of this
infinity war yeah it's it's fantastic
it's fantastic I'm so lucky I'm late to
the party but what a amazing thing to be
a small part of it's just it's very
special I mean especially coming off the
spider man in the success of love last
weekend I mean does it ever land on you
these fans and the world you guys are
putting out there just people can't get
enough that was this whole spider-man
experience to me that was the single
most crazy thing I've ever been through
right there just walking out on stage
everyone stood up I'm screaming and to
stand on stage with such an amazing
line-up of people thanks to each other
this is not good I could have had to
break this up hey hey we should start a
red carpet brawl between like all the
adventures I mean you just started war
who would win there's a few of us and
though the Americans are really strong
some of the British guys from the from
the Marvel Universe are out here and
they're saying that because there was
like a big Buffalo of them maybe they
should start like a British versus an
American kind of battle of the Marvel
Universe who do you think would win Drex
Hemsworth and you on the same team
forget to eat Thanos Josh Brolin you you
get to interact with everybody as much
as some of the superheroes do I would
think that I get to interact with all of
the characters from all 16 movies at
some point I want to spin off right here
I wanna I want an Avenger spin off of
these TVs we even wrote it yeah we wrote
it we wrote a short we shot it together
down when we pitched it to the studio so
it's just you know I don't have
[Music]
you